yeah welcome to this video bit of a late
start here somehow I had to had no sound
that I needed to fix that okay i'm
playing a sloth defense here against him
Grandmaster from France this even name
maxime la God yeah he can't say that I
know him yeah played the Slav the ship a
link 0 line and wow it's been a long
time that I studied that I had I did
some studies some a couple of years ago
when i played this line on her on a
regular basis
yeah I'd like to prepare a 5 here that's
probably the way I played this wasn't
too too precise okay I'm he's um
covering this c5 saw that on e5 see how
about hanging ok let's prepare this with
brookie 885 yeah he needs to be cautious
if he plays be five I have night take c5
the usual trickier this kind of position
where the bishop on g7 is strong piece
so he cannot play b5 really it's not a
problem I mean I wait I could have
played 85 myself this would have been
interesting ah lookee aid was a mistake
then but he doesn't react to that
interesting so a five he doesn't
consider to be a problem this is this is
interesting okay
did I blunder something I don't know
this is pretty easy trick of course no I
don't see how he what bigger surprises
got in store now it seems to be just a
pawn yeah okay so but I don't need to
move that yet at the moment it still
does hanging night but ok let's retreat
Adam prepare for 85 that's really am
still the move I want to play um the
only question is I could yeah I'd stoled
it I think it's still good
he doesn't really have a good way to put
pressure on c6 if he takes his 6pc 6 the
rock on c1 is nicely placed but the
knight on c3 is just blocking the way to
the pond the night H was really ugly are
interesting so it's trying to try to to
activate the t-con if all night takes
takes on d4 96's a point okay
so what no
take on
I'm not sure this is what was my idea
that it could be complete complete bogus
you don't really like to give it up but
it was a tactical idea no 96 with the
tempo and then deform his pieces are
somehow stepping on each other's toes if
I get in c5 and years t4 and then maybe
c5 it should be should be nice the only
thing is of course my king with g 6
plate he might have some idea with fy5
so he wants to go to c4 hmm yep
understandable oops no I wanted to go
here attacking here okay about an f5 I
have 95 attacking e four so this is
maybe not the end of the world Bishop a
six or does it misplace my bishop like
oh yeah now this is problem and was
briefly thinking about playing f5 myself
but this looks like looks looks insane
relief okay and yeah if I is the point
threatening to take them wow I this
could be good to time I mean
and jump and beg
if he takes on at five I just drop back
wait I'm on it down on one a minute yeah
didn't pay so much attention to the
clock situation
yeah the position I don't know I mean
maybe it is ok for me the king is a bit
open but ok this it's an extra pole
still and two passports so he needs to
get something something really quickly
so go here protect on f7 rook h5 I go
right on i def aid and where are you
going to air for maybe
yeah it's um with this with the time
situation i'm probably maybe I'm
objectively also bad but with the time
it gets its goods very tricky check da
rocha seven she said I needed to I need
to UM clicking kind words check the some
way to continue what can actually take
him it's made it still made crece seven
off towards me don't mine yeah okay ice
ball to win here pretty sure but it has
spent too much time really to to make it
to defend this properly around here
Black is just winning I wouldn't is also
supported by the computer but it's not
easy to play and he always has this
counter attacking possibilities yeah
here would be six yeah yeah I need to
play ruki six quite strange that I
didn't actually but rook f6 is already
better for white yeah my king is
smacking is intro on its own it's just
like that
and I probably need to to play a more
precise here around here blackest an
excellent shape but it's difficult to
defend okay this is prolly still oh
right here yes probably the point where
you need to improve and it is dangerous
yeah it is dangerous hard to tell really
of course this was was some very very
direct way to play that D takes you five
a black wins instantly yeah II for b3
edits too much that wins much much more
material yeah I didn't consider that so
probably this was the right move
Fletcher I continued in the wrong way I
mean this is not bad c5 but not c5 is
much stronger yeah an interesting game
thanks for watching